hello folks welcome to rational science
directly from frankfurt germany
it's nine o'clock over here
uh at night in the evening today we're
going to be talking about
distance whatever the
whatever distance is
and uh so
keep your distance
okay anyways uh we're going to be
analyzing a fellow who criticized the
scientific method
the genuine real scientific method
and we're going to analyze some of the
things he
said about the scientific method and
it's important because
a lot of people out there have the same
idea that he has
or ideas in general you know that
scientific method is doing fine
which we call the mathematical method
because all explanations are magical
for invisible and intangible entities
and
phenomena and so
you know uh we don't think that's
science
okay and there has been no improvement
in the last 2 500 years
in our understanding of gravity in our
understanding not 2 500 but a little
less than that in our understanding of
magnetism electricity the atom and uh
gravity
did i miss one um
i don't know if i missed one anyways the
deal is that
i'm saying that we haven't made any
progress whatsoever
in our understanding of the invisible
and intangible
entities and mechanisms that mother
nature uses daily
you know you drop a pen to the floor
why does it fall to the floor
after 2500 years not a single
mathematician on planet earth
can tell you the answer can give you an
answer and the reason is very clear
they can't see or touch
whatever serves as a mediator
and so they simulate their physical
interpretations with concepts with
abstract mathematical concepts and
people say oh i understood when they did
not understand anything you should be
able to explain gravity the way you
explain the workings of a car or
or whatever any physical mechanism and
that's not the case
they do not explain the mechanism
anyways uh this fellow um
uh attacked
certain aspects of the theory and of the
scientific method that we have and of
course
by
indirectly the theory right based on it
and
so this is where we start we start with
what he had to say this time we're going
to be analyzing a couple points that he
said
and here it goes give me a second here
and i'll turn it on there we go listen
to
what he's got to say about what he's uh
going to be criticizing what he's saying
that
about gravity especially
these are the questions and issues to be
resolved in this rejoinder
have the mathematicians made any
progress in men's understanding of
gravity in the last 400 years
does the theory of relativity explain
how gravity works
to act like there has been no new
discoveries in the last 400 years about
gravity is just plain wrong the theories
of relativity have definitely played a
part in furthering our understanding of
gravity
okay so that's the issue
and uh we'll concentrate mainly on the
last 400 years i'm saying that in 2500
years we haven't figured it out but 400
if we go with our last 400 years i think
we're doing fine we're going to be
answering the question okay let's see
what newton had to say about gravity
what his
uh
tremendous knowledge was about gravity
this is newton okay this is out of
principia out of his scolium okay here
it goes he says hitherto we have
explained the phenomena of the heavens
and our and of our sea by the power of
gravity but have not yet assigned the
cause of this power
it must proceed from a cause that
penetrates to the very centers of the
sun and planets without suffering the
least diminution of its force
there too i have not been able to
discover the cause of those properties
of gravity from phenomena and i framed
no hypothesis his famous
uh
saying you know he had no
theory no explanation for how gravity
works
and he says for whatever is not deduced
from the phenomena is to be called a a
hypothesis and hypothesis whether
metaphysical or physical weather of a
qualities or mechanical have no place in
experimental philosophy meaning uh
what they thought was science and what
still remains to be
to this day is considered to be science
experiment experiments or experimental
philosophy as he called it then and the
issue there is he's not going to be able
to detect
the mechanism of invisible intangible
gravity uh by doing an experiment
and this is where they failed right
there
and he continued says it is enough that
gravity does really exist
well we don't know about uh this uh
exist word because he hasn't defined it
and no one has in the last 2 500 years
so we don't know what he means when he
says that gravity does exist
okay what does he mean by that does god
exist what does he mean by that does the
chair exist what does he mean by that
unless we define the word exist we have
no idea what he just said
and act according to the laws which
we have explained and abundantly serves
to account for all the motions of the
celestial bodies and of rc
okay so this is the issue the issue is
that he had no clue how gravity worked
so
you can say that at least 400 years ago
it was probably the top honcho then 17th
century
he had no clue
okay he's he's staying at there you know
uh fingo nunn hypothesis or hypothesis
non-finger one of those two and meaning
i frame no hypothesis he had no clue how
it worked he he said yeah there's an
effect called gravity and that pulls on
the seas and whatever but he doesn't
know how that works how it's done
through
space in other words right okay so let's
uh fast forward let's go to
uh
what we have uh more recently in the
20th century we had a fellow his name
was albert einstein
and he's credited today with having
discovered gravity in fact this fellow
says that general relativity uh
explained gravity
warpage of space warpage of time
one of those two or both
and uh so let's see what einstein had to
say about it towards the end of his life
you know if you would have caught
einstein when he was 26 when he wrote
his uh first uh four papers that he
published in 1905 well he was a hot head
you know
he knew everything
but when he was about to die in the 50s
uh he became suddenly a very ignorant
man and here you see why he these are
his words by the way okay
okay and so here it is this is uh
you can see the dates here 54 and 49.
all these 50 years of conscious brooding
have brought me no nearer to the answer
to the question
what are like quanta
nowadays every time dick and harry
thinks he knows it but he is mistaken
i consider it quite possible that
physics cannot be based on the field
concept
in other words on continuous structures
in that case
nothing remains of my entire castle in
the air gravitation theory included and
of the rest of modern physics
and of course
they pushed him aside over there in
princeton where he was working the last
few years of his life
and he wrote these couple letters there
also he says i have become an obstinate
heretic in the eyes of my colleagues
because he did not believe in quantum
mechanics and he wasn't believing even
in general relativity anymore he became
an atheist in his own religion
and then he says i'm generally regarded
as a sort of petrified object rendered
blind and deaf by the years
einstein became a piece of furniture
towards the end of the life his life
nobody paid any attention to him he was
put in a corner there giving a big
salary because he was such a big name
and i guess he did more in that sense
for the uh princeton than princeton did
for him in the sense that hey we got
einstein here you know and that was all
it was worth
uh
he he died not understanding how gravity
works let alone quantum mechanics which
he didn't believe in
uh
you know in his entire life
so this is how it ends uh pretty much
because everybody now glorifies einstein
says oh einstein yeah what did he do for
science and he said well he invented uh
warp time
that's what he did he introduced warp
time now we do everything with warp time
okay
and so here's warp time folks this is
what this is
einstein's contribution to science
in a nutshell okay we have mass concept
mathematical concept and it bends this
sheet
this
i guess trampoline or canvas or whatever
you want to call it they call it a
fabric and what is that fabric made out
of is it made out of wool uh nylon what
is that uh a rubber band maybe uh no
those lines that you see stretching
there those are lines of time
and space but we're going to discard
space here we're interested in in saying
that what he's doing he's bending time
and how do you explain gravity by
bending time i mean that's okay to
describe that mathematically and say
look you know every time there's uh
this issue with gravity time uh seems to
run slower in some clocks that are out
there and faster over here and whatever
yeah that's that's fine those are
descriptions
we're talking about what is the
mechanism of gravity why doesn't the
earth fly out of the solar system why
does the moons fly out of the solar
system or fall towards the sun
you know so that's the physical
mechanism of what we're trying to get to
and of course this is ridiculous this is
this is absolute poppycock nonsense this
is but this is what people believe today
including this fellow okay
so you know i think he has a call to
laugh at people who
laugh at that
what you just saw
yeah that that is ridiculous nonsense
okay you don't say that the earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system
because time is warped that's
a ridiculous poppy it's nonsense and it
has no
validity whatsoever in science maybe at
the loony asylum but not in science
okay um
so some people uh came over and this is
pertinent to what this fellow said and
and they criticized what i said and i
said a little i think i said a little
something a little differently
but um
it was taken out of context
and i was referring to the fact to the
fact that in 2500 years no one has
figured out gravity or
magnetism or anything of that nature you
know the invisible things and
you can see here how everybody you know
went off on a tangent and they started
talking about something else one fellow
says
uh
first repeats what i said i'm saying
that we have made no progress in the
last 2 500 years what was i talking
about gravity specifically you know the
mechanism of gravity understanding what
the mechanism is what is he said says
the guy streaming audio and video to the
entire world what is he talking about
technology
and so again these people don't even pay
attention to what's going on
here's another fellow he says i'm saying
that we have made no progress in the
last 2 500 years and what is the answer
he says the fact that we can cure
illnesses which were death sentence just
200 years ago achieved flight split the
adam put humans on the moon sent
spacecraft to every other planet within
our solar system and a whole host of
other accomplishments discredits this
assertion completely your opinion
remains
just that without supporting evidence
so not only he's also uh introducing
technology or talking about technology
which had nothing to do with what what i
was talking about but on top of that he
says you need evidence
and uh what evidence for what is
evidence there to um
recruit people to convince them to
persuade them
what's the purpose of evidence
you know what evidence can i
provide for a mechanism
that i'm just explaining how gravity
works you know i just want to explain
why the spoon falls to the floor okay
if i want to explain that whatever am i
going to present whatever do you want
that's the question what evidence would
convince you
i mean what am i supposed to do you know
tell me and i'll present the evidence
that will convince you
so no evidence plays no role in science
absolutely not plays a role only in
religion in sunday school then you need
evidence because you're going to be
convincing people you're going to try to
persuade them to
believe like you do
that's not what we do in science in
science we explain a mechanism
objectively so that people understand
and that's where science ends what
continues after that is opinion belief
you know
religion
okay and yeah another fellow also said
something similar aren't these robes
just
also just a concept
no a rope is not a concept
this is not a concept this is a physical
object okay and that's why you need to
define what a concept is and what an
object is
and he says
what's the supposed difference to former
theories this is just switching out
words scientific method isn't perfect
but it provides helpful tools to predict
things and construct what new technology
if your theory or hypothesis doesn't
predict anything it's pretty much
useless
no no science is useless science has no
use whatsoever hopefully okay
science is only about explaining okay
now if that helps you in some way in
your
dark basement and you can
develop some device because of some
understanding in science well more power
to you but that's not the goal of
science science has nothing at all to do
with technology okay
science is only about explaining how the
universe works and that's where we have
made no progress in 2500 years no no
none whatsoever
okay none whatsoever not a single
mathematician out there who calls
themselves a phys
physicist mathematical physicist right
uh can explain to you how gravity works
or how magnetism works or how
electricity works they cannot
because as soon as they explain
something you know they're going to be
in deep trouble because you're gonna
explain it either with concepts which is
irrational you can't explain a mechanism
with concepts and then the other part is
that you know they explain it with
particles
and the problem with particles
assuming they were real particles which
they ain't okay by the way but assuming
they were real particles you know what's
known as classical particles how do you
explain attraction with particles
and you have to do you know a uh
ptolemaic explanation and
somehow push
the the two objects together from the
outside and maybe
take some stuff from the inside you know
they go through all these weird
processes to explain pull
via
push
it don't work that way mother nature
hopefully has a mechanism for pull and
the only way you can pull is putting
something between
the two objects okay and you know i i
have explained you can do this at home
you know
i explained that you know you have two
magnets those two
round ones there right and again don't
take my word for it do it at home
on your own right and you can feel that
there's there's nothing pushing on my
hands
from the outside you can feel that
there's a tug already from the inside
and don't take my word for it and go
prove it to yourself the tug is from the
inside and if it's from the inside you
only have two choices you either put
something there that's there that you
can't see or touch
or you do it with magic
okay
and magic involves using
what
uh
concepts mathematical concepts which
they introduce in lieu of objects
and that's the story of
for today for that one
okay let's move on uh
[Music]
we have today a uh bash build day
you're gonna be able to bash build today
okay
to some degree
here it is uh
this is bash build day you can throw uh
rotten tomatoes rotten eggs whatever you
got shoes
okay you get to do that today okay
okay why is that well because of this
subject it's uh the moonies okay
uh i talked about the moonies a couple
weeks ago
and what did i say well these are people
who believe we never went to the moon
okay
and why do you get the bash bill today
well because uh
they put the seed
of doubt in my mind
and you say oh bill we lost you
no no no hold on you can you can uh
lynch me later okay you wait
for the whole story don't lynch me yet
okay uh they put the seed of doubt in my
mind
as to whether we went to the moon
okay
and
you say well bill that means you're
gonna delete all these videos that you
put out there no no quite the contrary
if i get shown that i'm wrong that i was
irrational i'm going to leave them there
first so that you can embarrass me okay
that's one and should i deserve it if
that's the case right and the other one
is you know it serves as a
lesson as education for those people out
there
you know uh who are pros or cons it
doesn't matter it's it serves as a
as a good way of you know gauging
yourself okay
okay so what happened well one fellow
came over
and he said why don't you watch this
movie
it's a three-hour documentary on the
moon landing and it criticizes the moon
landing
it's known as american moon
okay and american moon uh goes over all
the uh i guess it's it's uh it takes
everything that everybody's uh
come up with out there all the arguments
and puts them in one movie and that's
good and i think it was well done the
movie was well done
one issue the other one that uh
surprised me is that you know i have two
issues with the moon landing primarily
and the first one was why didn't the
russians
criticize the americans
and say well these guys didn't really go
to the moon
you know
and that was one issue
the other issue is you mean nobody in 50
years i mean we're talking about 60s and
70s right and nobody in in all this time
50 60 years
at nasa you got like 400 000
uh people working uh subcontractors and
so on you know and no one working in
this whole project uh program or project
right uh ever noticed anything nobody
raised the flag and this is different
than 9 11 or kennedy's assassination you
know those happened in a very short time
here we're talking about 50 60 years
and nobody
ever raised a flag nothing
you know and i mean people working there
because you're working there and
you know it's all fake
you know and you say well what am i
doing here
just making a salary okay i'll push the
pencil and and you know and uh make a
salary okay if this is what they want
could it be
could that have happened
so these were the questions that i had
and it turns out that it's the first two
questions that the movie that the
documentary answers
and i thought they gave a pretty good
answer
so uh i decided to watch the whole three
hour
documentary i think it was worth it okay
and it uh you know opened my mind a
little bit on what happened see i hadn't
really researched a lot of these
subjects i just had those questions and
there was no need to investigate
anything any more than i would
investigate i don't know if santa claus
exists
you know why would i even do that if you
haven't shown
uh up front that you know i need to
investigate the existence of santa claus
you know something like that and here
these people weren't answering my
questions i was saying why didn't the
russians do it you mean for 60 70 years
nobody in nasa nobody raised the flag
nobody said hey this is all bs you know
nobody
and so you know uh those were my
questions nobody answered them i found
no reason to investigate the subject
this all sends uh this uh documentary
says go watch this okay
reluctantly and i watched okay and i
like the answers they gave to those two
questions first of all so let's go to uh
through some of these uh questions these
people uh
addressed in the uh documentary okay
one is the soviet silence okay why did
soviets keeps their mouths shut when
they could have said hey you know you
yanks
uh you're lying to the world yeah they
could have said that
uh four hundred thousand nasa workers or
even if you don't take all these
subcontractors just take the people at
nasa i don't know how many people are
working there there are all of these are
professionals you know and you're saying
all these people working there and
they're all faking it for 60 years
is this possible you know again
different than kennedy assassination or
9 11. you know those happen relatively
quickly
retro reflector on the moon you know uh
moon rocks being brought back they
analyze that
uh the photos lightning the lighting you
know the shadows they analyzed all that
uh green screen the horizon you know uh
so you do it in a studio and then you
put the green screen behind it they had
the technology to do that
in the 60s already
uh radiation you know uh the radiation
built the van helen belts
can we go through there etc can we not
uh they analyze that
no crater where the module put its legs
down you know i mean uh you had this you
had two issues there one where the
module comes down and blows everything
away they analyze that they analyzed
also you know is the moon
soft so you land on sand and if that's
the case should there be a footprint
there of the
leg of the module you know that kind of
thing
okay lost tapes
interesting stuff you know just
coincidentally they lost the tapes
and these are
uh
perhaps important tapes okay uh for
evidence why would they lose them why
would they destroy some of them saying
that they took up a lot of space they
could have given them to a museum for
example you know and that sort of thing
so they analyze these situations a lot
of those i think are good arguments okay
uh the speed of the replies they gave a
couple of examples where uh houston said
blah blah blah and the other guy answers
a little too fast
for what the signal should have been
between you know
emission and coming back the astronaut
had to hear it first and then give an
answer
and it's like you know when you look at
the timing it was a little too close
okay and so that's a valid issue okay
flag waving you know i've heard of some
of these arguments by the way in the
past i heard about flag waving and uh
this time i looked a little closer at
some of these things
was the flag waving because the
astronaut hit it or he went by and you
know somehow there was some interaction
between the astronaut and the flag
another issue with the flags is uh they
can't see them
nobody can see them with a telescope
so they had
one
orbiter go in there and they said oh we
were able to take pictures of the flags
and again uh
it's nasa who's telling you this so it's
like you know the the fox guarding the
hand again you know the hens
i don't know i can't tell you i'm not in
the moon to check the flags question
would be what if the chinese
uh 10 20 30 years from now you know they
land on the moon and they don't find
plagues where they should be what are
they going to say
and i'm sure they're going to have
assuming that's the case you know
nasa would have an answer saying maybe
you know the solar wind blew them away
okay
and uh
again you know the
nasa issued a policy where they didn't
want people getting anywhere two
kilometers from
the sites
where the astronauts landed okay
and they say to preserve it for history
we want to preserve that area with the
footprints and all the flags and all
this stuff and the stuff that they left
there
and it's like you know we don't want
anyone
to uh within 2000 kilometers from that
area
and that's again uh it's suspicious
because a lot of people would say hey
you know all you're trying to do is
protect
um
you know your
your um
the fact that you never went there
that's the issue okay
and but as far as the flags are
concerned all i can tell you same with
the retro reflector you know uh you
don't need to put humans there you can
you can
have a an automatic orbiter you know a
robot of some kind
come down to the to the moon and and do
it for
you know in lieu of a human so
uh you know those things can be done
without human in fact the russians put
their retro reflector with
without putting a human over there you
know they did it all artificially so you
know again if there are retro reflectors
and other equipment on the moon that
does not prove that someone went on the
moon okay
and so here are some of the answers that
they gave me
which i kind of liked for the first two
questions okay here's the first question
why didn't the soviets deny that the
americans went to the moon and i kind of
liked their answer and it was the first
two there no one would have believed
them
uh because just uh because you know the
soviets had just lost the race against
the yanks to the moon
and that is a good answer that is a good
answer yes i don't think anybody would
have believed the soviets if they went
out there and said oh yeah you never
went to the moon you did it all in
hollywood
uh nobody would have believed them i
agree with that statement that's the
first one then the other one is um the
soviets had uh coming up a a joint space
program with the americans
and they were gonna do stuff together
and it's like you know do we care if
they were the first you know we had the
first
uh soviet astronaut uh gagarin who
orbited the earth
we have a first woman first dog
you know i mean give them one first as
well it's like you know does it matter
you know is that so important that they
would sacrifice having a joint mission
where you know americans and uh russians
could go out in space and work together
it's like it's a trivial thing in the
end okay so i thought that was a good
answer too
and
uh one argument someone else raised okay
says that each side knew the other was
faking their missions
so it's like a liar calling the liar a
liar
in a
kettle calling the pot black you know
so they wouldn't blow the whistle on
each other if they were both faking it
so that's another possibility another
thing you got to keep in mind not that
any of these are real i'm just saying
some of these are good arguments i just
want you to listen to them okay that's a
that's all for now okay
it's uh i put those two at the bottom
not a big deal to swallow the story that
the other side was first okay i don't
think
it was a big deal
you know the russians probably would
have said you know we would have loved
to be first but they beat us to it
you know so and they did it in hollywood
and they beat us on that and we could
have done it in our hollywood here but
they did it first or whatever you know
it was not a big deal in the end okay
just uh put their names and lights in
the history books that's all it was
and uh then the other one is that that i
came up with is that you know this is um
what happened was primarily for
americans uh consumption for the public
american public's conception
you know the russians have their own
news
factory
they tell their people whatever they
want and the americans tell their people
what they want so it's like you know
each one tells them whatever they want
and
you know you can tell them anything you
want like in the case of 9 11 the
americans
tell their people that you know this was
done by bin laden and who knows what the
russians tell their people or the
chinese air people
because they have their own uh news
factories you know the everybody makes
fake news in every country
so
i don't know what to tell you you know
uh i i you know
this this whole thing was really for uh
consumption by um the american public so
it's like the russians say okay so go
ahead and tell them whatever you want
so if if you did it in uh in a little in
a little studio
and you want to tell them that you went
to space go ahead you know we're not
going to tell that to our people
okay so this is
another issue there
okay uh here's uh the second question
you know the
how can so many people be
have been kept in the dark especially
people who work directly with nasa you
know the professionals that work there
okay
and um so they frames the question in in
the documentary were 400 000 nasa
employees involved in the scan
i phrased it a little differently but
along the same lines could they have
faked all the missions and fooled nasa
workers for the last 60 years
no one ever found out
okay
and so
you know those were the
reasons i never researched in any detail
this stuff because i never had good
answers to those two questions the
russians and this one
and so uh their answer is not everyone
should be in the know
and yeah that's that is exactly how this
works if there is a conspiracy if there
is a conspiracy and there was fake
um
projects
that weren't really being carried out
then yeah nobody has to you don't tell
everybody
that's the first one then yeah you know
all they had to do was like these people
say take control of the tv signals okay
and by this time they had developed
uh
a map of the
uh
lunar surface they had a globe there and
they had filmed it so they had the
material there to carry it out
so it i mean it's it is within the
possibilities that's all i'm saying it's
it's a possibility
and then
the first people to be do would have
been you know those people there
those are the ones you want to fool
and you don't want them going out there
and and telling people well it's all
fake you know don't believe in it you
know you want them to believe it
you know i'm doing a good work where do
you work i work at nasa i work in the
control center in houston and what do
you do well i communicate with the
astronauts see if the guy actually
believes it it's very different
than the guy not believing and saying
well you know i worked there i pushed a
pencil around
you know he he would say or he might
even tell his wife or his kids or his
friends saying you know it's all bs
he could have done that right no you
have to make those believe first and so
if you have control of the signals of
the tv and all that stuff that you're
gonna put into you're gonna feed into
those computers well the first people
you're going to fool are the people in
the control center
so i thought those were at least uh
valid answers okay uh those
uh
those are good alibis you know okay so
yeah and uh here's uh
here's the third one that i mentioned
okay why haven't we gone to the moon
since then
you know and um
i always answer well there's no need to
go to the mall
you know uh what are we gonna do get
collect moon rocks jump around
place a flag is is that why we should go
to the moon i mean you know again if we
haven't gone in the last 60 years the
question is was there any reason to go
in the first place
and yeah you can say look even in those
days or even today you know why we would
go today and here i i put a
impromptu list is you want to develop
technology that's a valid reason to go
to the moon okay
great jobs here on earth obviously you
know the government suddenly throws a
bunch of billion dollars into the a
project and all that money gets spread
around into
subcontractors and so on so it creates
jobs so that would be one of the reasons
that they would stimulate
a uh project of going to the moon
um military reasons you know uh strategy
and so on you know maybe they gain some
advantage over the other side by going
into space and
checking out certain strategies and
tactics that they can use i think that's
a valid one also you know very powerful
one in fact uh because it would fall
under the military budget perhaps
certain projects okay
prepare for mars obviously if we're
going to go to mars maybe a better
deal is to stop by the moon first and
make sure you can get to the moon and do
that several times be comfortable with
that maybe even put a station there and
then say okay we can do what we're doing
here on the moon we can do this in mars
as well
so i think that's a valid issue hope
give hope to humanity that you know uh
we're all going out of this planet maybe
put colonies in space or on some other
artificial
or satellite or whatever uh that would
give hope to people and that's positive
as well so i think that would be another
reason that
people would uh you know the powers that
be would try to go to the moon
mining i don't think so
i don't think they're going to mind the
moon ever because
just the taking the equipment up there
is going to be a monster it's going to
be requiring it's going to require
several trips
uh i'm not sure there's going to be
budget for all that
maybe you know it's a possibility but i
doubt it and i'm not sure how easy it
would be to mine the moon and they would
have to explore first i mean what are
they going to find dinosaurs uh
underneath the rock
uh oil
if oil is made through you know
what is it plant material or whatever
you know down here
uh
you know maybe mine some rare mineral
would it be worth it to go to the moon
to get that rare mineral or is it easier
to get it here on earth so i don't know
if mining is ever going to be
ever going to happen or if it's ever
going to be profitable okay even
transporting it back you know let alone
creating the
uh infrastructure to be able to mine
down there okay and then i cannot
imagine you know uh mining where they're
gonna go into the caves and start mining
uh then loading it onto carts and then
how much can they bring back a couple
rocks in a little rocket they would need
a um a vehicle maybe the size of the
skylab you know to bring stuff like that
back or even bigger okay so we're not
talking about uh you know loading a
truck here and bringing it down here
it's you're talking about a little
capsule that's going to bring you know
what is it a rock maybe a couple of
rocks
no um i don't think mining is ever going
to happen
and surely we're not going to plant
potatoes okay so don't tell me that
we're going to be doing what the fellow
in mars did you know in the movie that
he got stuck in mars and he started
planting potatoes
i don't think so
okay
so
where'd he go from here i mean
should i believe in these people should
i not believe in them
uh should i believe we went to the moon
or should i not believe that we meant to
the moon what's the story here
well all i can tell you is they put the
bug of doubt in me okay
uh because of some of the things that
happened
and let's see if i can find it here um
here's uh one of the issues they raised
that uh
you know
again uh was a red flag for me okay
and that's uh
something that happened there and had to
do with the administrator james webb
okay
and here's the timeline there was a big
accident apollo 1 okay killed three of
the astronauts
and uh that was before they went on on a
flight this was just like a practice you
know and they got killed on earth here
and so three of these astronauts died
because of that that triggered a series
of things one of them was that you know
the nasa deputy director robert siemens
he quit a short while ago
and a little later
we have this nasa administrator james
webb quit
and so the argument these people raised
in the documentary is that
you know kind of suspicious here's these
guys
and
they always wanted to get to the moon it
was like their lifelong dream
and they quit a few months before
remember this uh we got to the moon in
60 july 69
these guys quit in 68 and they had been
on the project for several years
suddenly they quit
and suddenly we got to the moon
that's the way they presented the case
uh in the in the documentary and uh
james webb says he states that in march
1967 that the possibility of doing all
the necessary work this year to put a
man on the moon before the decade is
less than it was last year
so things were getting worse
and here they had also a guy who you
know the
the capsule there they died they were
burned alive these three astronauts so
that was a big shock and now these
people are saying you know
we need more money we need more funds
and they're giving them and if they say
well we give you more funds and and you
have this big accident
we're having a problem here what's going
on
and uh by this time it's important to
note that nasa had mapped the surface of
the moon and had built a mock-up which
they filmed in the nasa studio you know
it turns out that this uh nasa globe
uh the moon you know they built the
globe there was a perfect copy of the
moon
uh which they could quickly film you
know and which they did film
because they had mapped the surface of
the moon with um
with some of the orbiters
and so they had the technology
to fool people
on top of that you have this big
accident at the last moment and you have
these two people who are career nasa
people
and they quit at the last moment a few
months
before they finally reached the moon
the situation is worthy of being
inspected no doubt about it it's a good
argument okay
and again i'm being objective here
without any
pre
conditions you know i want to be as
honest as i can here okay so there is
doubt they say oh did these guys quit at
the last moment and it was their
lifelong dream
and then to top it off
uh the movie ends there's many are you
gotta watch the movie you know to find
out exactly everything that they said
and all the arguments they make but here
it goes and i'm going to show you the
last part of the movie okay the last
part of the movie is also
kind of shocking for me i was not aware
of a lot of this stuff okay and here let
me present it to you listen carefully
this is the three astronauts who went to
the moon
and they have a
a conference and you know a press
conference
and they're gonna tell you how excited
they were to go to the moon and
you know how they they're so gung-ho
about it about having gone there and
they're so excited and they're willing
to tell everybody on earth of their
success so please listen to this which
is i think
quite revealing
here it goes okay go then on september
16 they appear for a press conference in
front of the global members of the press
who welcomed them with a standing
ovation
everyone expects to see three absolute
heroes radiating with happiness and
pride for their incredible achievement
but their faces appear somber tense
somehow preoccupied instead they seem
uncomfortable and there are several
truly embarrassing moments during the
event when the three astronauts are
asked the meaning of a mission that has
brought mankind on another celestial
body for the first time the three don't
seem too eager nor too enthusiastic
about answering the question many of us
and many other people in many places
have speculated on the meaning of this
first landing on another body in space
would each of you give us
your estimate of what is the meaning of
this to all of us
and when armstrong describes their
achievement as the beginning of a new
era he seems more like a person forced
to read from a script than someone
actually convinced of his own words the
entire program
it's
a beginning of
a new age
what new era was he talking about new
era of fakery or what
like
we're gonna be lying from now on is that
is that what they were
referring to
i mean these three fellas did not
look
enthusiastic at all
and i was wondering why why would that
be the case i mean i thought it was
quite shocking to be honest with you
and then the other thing is that you
know there was this
crazy pastor who ran after them and
tried to get their
put their hand on the bible swearing
that they were on the moon
and not one of the three put their hand
on the bible and swore to it
now there's two arguments there one was
that you know that can be used in a
court of law because the guy swears you
know on the bible and then that can be
used against them i don't think it was
that case but the question is
why didn't they swear on the bible now
the pastor was a little
over insistent
okay so he went out of his way he should
have been a little more calm but yeah
the issue is they weren't willing to
swear in the bible that they went to the
moon and you can see that they were not
very enthusiastic
and to make matters worth uh all three
of them quit
nasa right after they uh this mission
all that is suspicious to me okay and
that's all i can tell you i'm just being
objective here okay i'm not saying it is
it ain't i'm just saying that is
suspicious
okay so uh
how did i look at this uh web fellow
okay james webb
um
why did he quit
and so it's important to put it in the
proper context so that we have the other
side of the story okay and again i'm
being as objective as i can here no
preconditions okay
and so this is the timeline here you
have the apollo disaster in january 67
by february you have the phillips report
come out
it came out originally it was supposed
to be a verbal report like you know the
guy goes in there inspects and says this
is what's happening with nasa especially
in relation to this north american
aviation company that was preparing the
some of the equipment you know
manufacturer of the command service
module with csm
and uh
and other parts you know so
these people were not only uh
behind schedule
they were
asking for more money they were there
was a cost overrun and on top of that
you know you have this apollo disaster
so everything was against them and so
the phillips report became something
written
and uh some people in congress think it
was a walter mondale the democrat who
found out about it and so they began a
an inquiry
uh into the death of the three
astronauts and they discovered this
report uh that was out there okay the
phillips report
and
so they started investigating said look
there's all these problems there
and so
i think what happened and again this is
the other side of the story uh
you know because of that disaster and
because of the way things were going and
because of the fact that there was an
investigation and so on uh
congressional investigation uh i think
that's one of the reasons the first guy
quit robert siemens
and the question is why did the second
guy quit uh at the end of the year when
it was his lifelong dream he's the guy
who started this whole thing james webb
what did he quit
and uh
i have a couple ideas he was a democrat
he was put in there by kennedy
stayed there with through johnson and
now you've got nixon coming up because
he won the election he's a republican
and maybe there was al already some
murmuring that they were going to
replace him because it's the president
who designates who
takes charge of nasa okay
and
you know i think it's contextual uh
there were reasons other than
um the fakery
uh that made uh james webb quit now it
could have been also been i mean you can
take a lot of arguments here one is that
maybe he would maybe they came to him
and they said look you can't make it
fake it
uh you can't make it to the moon fake it
to the moon okay and so
he said well i'm not gonna do it and so
maybe that's why he quit
i mean you can come up with a hundred
arguments and the issue there is that
you know james webb is dead so we cannot
ask him
uh we can't rely on the party line you
know to tell us why he quit what were
the
things in the background
uh that's lost in history all we can say
is he did quit and uh shortly after
suddenly the apollo program takes off
you know not only
do
we have
apollo 8 uh go out there right but by
the time you get to apollo 11 um
you know a few months later and they're
off to the moon they landed on the moon
and with so many problems that they were
having could test have been
realistic i mean is this believable
okay so that's the question okay we
start with a question let's find out if
we can get some answers here
okay
i can only tell you my reasoning here
okay and uh you know you follow along
and you decide for yourself
okay so the first question i've got is
uh
uh you know if if we're gonna go to the
moon and i know this because i ran
projects million dollar projects okay
if you're gonna do a project there are
many steps that you have to take before
you reach
your goal okay especially in something
as important as this going to the moon
this is not you know kid stuff you gotta
you know guarantee almost every step if
you can you know so say uh first you do
this part then you move to this part
then you move to that part so you have
to go in steps you can't just go to the
moon one day and say i think i'm gonna
go to the moon take my rocket and get
out there okay so there's steps involved
okay you cannot elude some of these
steps some of them are mandatory okay
and so the question is let's start here
have we ever gone into space
because you have different people with
different incredulity out there some
people believe some things other people
don't even believe that much and others
believe even less
and so the question is you know you
gotta you gotta try to address step by
step people who you have flat earthers
who do not believe we ever went into
space and that we're communicating
through little sardine cans and you know
a little wire connected underneath the
ground
you know they don't believe in
satellites and why don't they believe in
satellites very simple because if they
send something out into space
for example satellite and that can take
a picture of the earth from a far well
then you could show that the earth is
round you know circle not flat
and so they have to deny that
okay so that's their argument they said
we never went into space
okay uh that's a little extremist
okay the question is have we ever gone
into space
have we ever gone to the moon at all in
any way shape or form have we ever sent
any probe any whatsoever satellite uh
little probe whatever to the moon
or even into outer space so we got to go
step by step okay
and for this i'm saying
let's go with something which is
verifiable okay
any person on earth can verify
okay
you've probably heard of the iss the
international space station
it's a monster that is orbiting the
earth
at i think 500 miles above uh sea level
here okay
and uh
you know the question is this is
something you can see with your own eyes
let alone
with a pair of binoculars or with a
little telescope
if uh you know nasa publishes the route
so you can wait for it if it goes near
your house or your friend's house who
lives in some in canada or wherever and
you say look point at the sky see if you
can see something there i mean there
should be a way for you to verify that
there's an iss an international space
station
a monster
a big we're not talking a little two by
four gagarin capsule we're talking about
a monster that is out there flying
around the earth that you can verify
with your own eyes
okay 500 miles out there you can still
see it because why because it's little
but you can see it with your eyes they
say and i haven't seen it okay i haven't
seen it but here uh you have people all
over the world uh um
you know
people who are enthusiasts um
people who are not professionals you
know these people they put their
telescopes they put their cameras and
they film these things okay and here's
one film of it okay
and here you can see that little dot
bright dot
okay going through the sky and that's
the skyland
i'm sorry the iss the international
space station and it's going to come
from the right now you can see it there
okay so there's something floating out
there
orbiting the earth
far away that you can look up with your
telescope or with your pair of
binoculars
okay there is
uh this
big monster floating out there
and so if you deny this uh it's very
simple for you to prove it to yourself
okay it's not an airplane it's not man
okay it's not a
a duck
it's a space station and you can prove
it to yourself with binoculars okay
that's that's the first step
and so the question is did we send the
iss up there
one day to the next without doing
anything in between did we say oh why
don't we just send the space station out
there
and put it into orbit
around the earth
and again it's this is not an airplane
because this go this is going around and
around you can watch it every day so
this is not an airplane the airplane
would run out of fuel
okay and this guy is going around and
around and around
and it doesn't look like an airplane
either so if you get your binoculars
your telescope whatever you've got or
your friend who lives over there in some
in africa or whatever then you can you
know have a verification that there is
uh this iss uh orbiting the earth
okay
now again did we send this thing up
there from one day to the next
no in order to send that thing up there
there had to be a million steps before
that
okay you don't just one day wake up and
say i'm gonna send a a big space station
up there okay no there's a bunch of
steps in between you have to send one
rocket you have to send you know uh
capsules that orbit the earth first
uh maybe first uh without a human then
later on you try it with a human you
know and you risk his life
maybe you send a dog you know like leica
you know
so you you have these steps and you say
well let's let's start let's start out
small okay we send this guy then we send
the other guy then the other guy
so there's a bunch of steps you develop
rockets you
improve the capsules you create the
suits which you test
in vacuum okay and so on
and and so you've got all these steps
before you can send the space station
and so you cannot say there has never
been a human that or or a probe at least
that has gone to space
of course there have been probes that
have gone to space for those people
who have a problem with belief at that
level
okay
we have sent
satellites and probes into space and the
question is did we just send them
right here a few miles away and then
bring them back
or have there been any probes that have
gone
outside the earth orbit for example you
know like
beyond the uh van allen belts
uh maybe to the moon
maybe to mars
have we ever sent anything to the moon
or to mars at all to venus
maybe the mercury
we never sent anything out there
we don't have the technology to do this
okay so let's go slowly here let's go
step by step i'm saying the iss took a
long time to develop and all the steps
that you need to take in between are
that you need to send probes out there
not necessarily with people in but
certainly you have to send
the probes out there the first one and
the question is if you can send a
monster like the iss into orbit i'm sure
we can send a smaller capsule all the
way to the moon without people in it
without anything in it just send it in
there you know and maybe even have it
orbit the moon okay
and then why not if you send that well
you can send some other stuff in there
now the other issue here is uh whether
we
have sent humans into outer space okay
and so again i'm gonna go to the iss and
find out if there's anything in there
except uh just um
you know a floating
monster out there other people working
at the iss is there anyone in there or
is it uninhabited
and so here you see this okay i'm gonna
show you
a couple examples a lady who's out there
okay or was at least then a fellow okay
and these two astronauts found out that
astronauts are those who go beyond a
certain level out there you know in
space they're known as astronauts
otherwise they're just pilots
and so these are astronauts they went
out into space they're floating around
you can see that okay
and uh you can see the uh little
uh
computer he's got there uh you know a
laptop uh tiny laptop uh and it's
floating around
and you can say well that's all done
with wires
is that done with wires
i mean is this done in here on earth in
a uh
in a studio is this uh photoshopped are
we talking about green screen here is
this what this is all about i mean look
at the guy he's moving
uh with um i mean assuming he's being
held by wires which is one of the
arguments out there uh i don't think you
can reproduce this with wires not this
neatly okay
and you can see the uh
water ball floating and the lady just
swallowing it
okay um
i don't think you can reproduce this
here on earth in a lab
okay i think this is real
okay
and
they say these people are in the sky lab
and where else could they be if not in a
sky lab to do these
gravity tricks okay
now
people say well you know there are
tricks and tricks and all kinds of stuff
and here let me show you a couple of
tricks okay
and this is done here essentially on
earth this is done by pilots not by
astronauts
and what it is is that you're in this
airplane that flies at a given um
angle
at a certain speed and because of that
creates momentarily for about 20 seconds
it creates this gravity-less environment
and then you fall back to the floor it
lasts about 20 seconds
that wasn't the case in the people you
just saw because those people
are days
and months up there working in in the
sky lab
oh yeah i'm sorry in the iss so you
cannot compare this which is a momentary
thing which is a great thrill i'm
sure
uh you cannot compare this against what
you just saw
okay and so let me show you another one
now
which again it's because people raise
all these issues and here's uh mr david
copperfield and he does this magic trick
okay and he goes flying through the air
okay this is done in a uh
in an auditorium and they pass these uh
rings through them
uh showing that there's no strings
nothing holding him no no uh wires or
anything okay
and uh and there he takes even the gal
you know lifts her off her feet okay
and yeah when you see this uh you say
well yeah if this can be done in in real
life in front of people
you know the guy flying through the air
this is again in a stage
uh
and
we all know it's a trick
then of course the other guy we did it
as a trick as well
but see the other fellows they were in a
cramped uh area first of all second this
one is done with wires okay and the
trick again is how they pass the rings
through the wires and how they
pass on through that box that
glass box and so on this is all done
with wires okay and that's why he is
able to fly like that like superman but
see he's in a stage where they can do
this from above from far away so that
and they can mask the wires okay
you cannot do this in that small cramped
space where you just saw the asteroid go
through a little hole
please show me how they did it there
especially with his tablet you know
rolling around and the guy has to stop
it and so on yeah sure
now if you don't believe that well then
you have a problem you really have a
problem i have to say that there is a
international space station out there
there are people on it they're floating
around in anti-in in low gravity or
almost zero gravity right
and they're floating around they're
working there and that's the thing that
you're seeing over there
uh you know orbit the earth and if
that's the case
you cannot have put those people out
there in space
uh overnight there had to be some steps
a lot of steps before you could do that
among them you had to send a man to
orbit the earth
low orbit
you know these are low orbits but uh
you're talking about people out there
way beyond
what a um what a pilot does
and if the guy spends six seven eight
days out there going around the earth
yeah we're talking about a rocket we're
not talking about an airplane okay so
all these things you gotta keep in mind
if you're gonna be objective about it
okay for rational people the irrational
flat earthers you know
they they should go somewhere else okay
okay so these are some of the milestones
i came up with that are necessary if
you're going to send someone to earth uh
into the moon and also if you want to
build a iss okay uh
international space station okay
and most of these milestones were done
by the soviets that's interesting about
it uh they they created the first
milestone and almost all in fact i think
all of them two or three months later
were done by the americans
so it was like you know the first lunar
flyby couple months three months later a
few months later the americans did it
first lunar impact a few months later
the american city and so on i don't know
if that was scheduled that way or it was
that the russians were ahead in the race
i think it's irrelevant okay
uh they sent the probe to mars
far away i mean if they send it to
the moon
why not to
mars is is there an impediment to do
this to send it to mars
and then
they have a lunar lander
they landed
something artificially on the moon okay
so they went to the moon not only did
they go to the moon orbit the moon but
they put a lunar land or something that
fell on the moon okay
then they had the lunar orbiter you know
uh
again you know this um lunar vehicle
that went around the moon
and then they had a lunar lander and
first lift off from the moon to see if
they could get the vehicle back to earth
okay so they did all these tricks before
they went in there and sent humans or
did the iss for sure they had to go
through these steps
otherwise you don't get an iss out there
you have to go through these steps
or some of these at least okay
then they sent some live turtles to
orbit the moon in 1967
okay
and uh
you say well well did that happen
okay uh could the
russians have really sent this is on
five
to the moon with two live turtles the
first ones to cross the van allen belts
for those of you who believe you would
be zapped to death
okay these two turtles they went there
not only turtles they sent some other
anima i think worms or whatever
they went to the moon
orbited came back
alive they got them out of the ocean and
they were alive after a few days
and you say well that's a lie i don't
believe in that
okay why do i believe in that
well i can tell you the following uh on
the one hand the americans didn't say
you you lied that's one okay so it's the
other the foot's on the other the shoes
on the other foot now
uh you know the reason i believe it is
that there was no propaganda for the
mission
you know after they they
sent the uh probe to space it wasn't
like
like 72 hours later they told the press
in russia like oh by the way we sent a
couple of turtles out there
so you would think that you know i mean
when they went to the moon for the first
time uh orbit the moon and come back and
when they went the second time to land
someone on on on the moon actually
it was big news all over the world
believe me no one missed it like no one
missed 911 no one missed the moon
landing no one missed kennedy's
assassination those things were covered
worldwide
these people sent through turtles to the
moon and you would think that they'd
make a a big stink about it say hey we
did this
nothing at all
it's like it's just a project you know
we're we're sending up turtles
so that's why i believe they sent it
because they didn't make a a big
thing about it it's just like we sent
them got them back okay we accomplished
the project that we set out to do let's
move on to another project it was just
like routine work
that's why i believe that the turtles
did actually go to the moon and back
okay and i think it was the americans
who recovered it out of the pacific or
indian ocean i think that was the case
so you know i have to believe that
that's the case that the turtles did go
to the moon after all they didn't land
on the moon they just orbited the moon
and came back that's it okay
and again the residents were trying to
figure out if they could get something
alive to the moon and back that was it
that was the project and if they died
well poor turtles let's
put a cross in their tunes
okay
okay and um
so the question there is you know here's
uh the first humans uh went out there
um beyond the uh valon belts and they
orbited the moon just a couple months
later after
after the russians sent the turtles
were they working together the russians
and uh americans because to me it's
strange it's strange for me okay
that the americans would not have sent
uh
animals first to the moon or or anywhere
beyond the uh valon belts
on the other hand they already had the
information from the russians that oh
they sent them to the
to to the moon and back
maybe even like i say maybe the
americans recovered that and gave it
back to the russians i can't hear your
turtles
and so
they said okay it happened it can be
done there's no problem there maybe they
didn't need to run
live animals you know uh
to the moon because it was already done
by the russians why repeat that
so you know you have arguments on both
sides that's all i'm saying well they
send these uh humans and they just orbit
the moon could that have been
possible well if they sent all these
probes and i just put a few of them i
haven't put all of them i just put the
ones that were the milestones that you
know achieved some
very important goal but there were
others there were eight alone between
the americans the russians
in the in 1966 alone to the moon
orbiters landers etc they sent a lot of
probes out there okay
did they happen well if if we have the
iss out there they had better had some
intermediate steps and these are
intermediate steps not
i mean the iss hasn't gone to the moon
but the point is that if you can send
the iss out into space and build this
monster out there you can definitely
send a small
uh probe to the moon
i mean what are we talking about it's
just a rocket it's no big deal in that
sense it's not uh unthinkable
so yeah i think they did send these pros
to the moon they went around and they
came back
and if they did it several times and
they did it with all these rockets and
they say okay we we've tweaked the
rockets we can send them out to the moon
we can get the rocket to orbit the moon
and come back
well not why not try it with humans
why not do it with humans if that's the
goal
at some point you got to try that one as
well
okay and so i have no problem believing
the apollo 8 went to the moon went
around the moon and came back
uh there was a some danger in the sense
that you know you orbit the moon and
then come back well maybe you go into
the middle of space but that's why they
test these things out with a with you
know with the boosters and so on
whatever they need and they come back
so i don't think that
uh there's an impediment through this
whole
uh series of projects
for humans to have gone at least to the
moon
let alone you know uh i mean
when we're talking about um landing
someone on the moon that's a little
different but again if they sent
something to the moon and then got it
back because they have these landers
and they do the landers and they say
okay it works and just in case i did it
again and they did it again it works
again well then what are you going to
say
if we can land something on the moon and
get it back into the
module and then bring
the whole thing back to earth after
three days
i don't think it's unthinkable
okay
now uh
you got to put in there you know the
fact that these guys
uh which shocked me really you know they
were so
down so
like they didn't want to talk
you would think again like the
documentary says they would be jumping
with joy
and that wasn't the case that struck me
as something very odd okay and that kind
of put the seed of
doubt in me a little seed i don't know
if it's gonna
bloom into a flower into a tree
okay um um
i'm withholding
my
my opinion yet because i don't really
know okay all i can do is tell you i'm
gonna be investigating this uh
you know as a hobby okay i think it's
got some merit okay there could be also
uh
some other versions where maybe they
weren't ready for the first lunar
landing
and so maybe they faked the first lunar
landing because of some politics behind
it whatever
and maybe that's why these three
astronauts you know were so shy
at the press conference maybe they
cheated maybe they lied
but maybe the other uh guys you know by
that time nasa got its act together and
they were able to send you know apollo i
mean they said they had a problem with
apollo 13 okay great but then they said
you know 12 14 15 all the way to 17 and
uh
maybe those were real and maybe the
first one was unreal
i mean you know i don't know all i can
tell you is there are different
arguments
of um
that need to be researched
and
if i get caught in a in in my
uh
it's not a lie because i was honest i'm
being as honest as i possibly can i'm
trying to get to the bottom of it but if
i find out that it was all a hoax by the
united states government and the russian
government because it would be on both
sides right
uh
no problem it's not the first time in my
life that
i changed my mind and some so so deep
okay
okay so let's move on to um
distance what is distance
so how did this distance thingy start
well uh
it started i think a lot uh with
surveying they surveyed the land in the
days of
old 3 000 4 000 years even before christ
you know they were building these
structures these buildings pyramids
uh all kinds of buildings and you know
the architects or the people who
eventually
got the hang of it you know they had to
measure the land
and so one of the issues was is that
they weren't concerned with physics
with a distance of physics like distance
of physics is just separation that's it
that's all mother nature understands she
doesn't understand one meter one foot
one inch she don't understand any of
that she only understands separation
that she understands
and this is not what these people did
they had to measure the land and they
had to have you know so many feet so
many inches and so on and they had their
own measurements obviously their own
units but they had to measure to find
out how much
and that's how you know this distance
thingy
entered into the world of math and
really into the world of geometry okay
and so here you have an example of that
okay um
you know what was geometry all about how
did it start well it started with land
measurement that's what geometry means
geo you know uh land and metri
measurement that's what it is it's land
measurement what were they measuring
were they measuring time
with a measuring motion
they were measuring distance but not
distance of physic they were measuring
distance traveled
traveled by whom by the end of your
measuring tape or whatever they used to
measure the distance so they were
looking at units how many units is it
from here to there
that's what they were concerned about
and then
they started doing some math some
rudimentary math and they eventually
developed you know a lot of this uh
arithmetic first and math and all this
other stuff that went hand in hand with
so-called geometry measurement of the
land why because they're going to
measure
they're going to get numbers they're
going to get units okay
so the earliest records beginnings of
geometry can be traced to ancient
mesopotamia and egypt in the second
millennium bc and i'm sure even before
then i'm almost sure that you go three
thousand maybe even four thousand years
ago you would have measurements and
these people are the only ones that
maybe document started documenting a lot
of that okay early geometry was a
collection of empirically discovered
principles concerning what
lengths
was it length that was distance traveled
that's what they call length they're
unrolling the measuring tape to measure
the length of the table what are they
measuring distance travel not the net
length okay so
length is just you know continuous
matter from one edge to the other that's
what length is but when you put some
numbers and units to it now you're
talking about something else okay so
that's what it is measurement okay
angles areas and volumes which were
developed to meet some practical need in
surveying
yes it was a practical meaning never
talking about technology not about
science okay they were talking about we
got to do something we got to build
something we got to make it practical
it's got to have some use
and that's got nothing to do with
science science is about discovering how
mother nature runs the you know her shop
that's what science is about uh this
this is technology okay
uh construction astronomy and various
crafts yeah you know that's what it is
it's uh what we call technology so
that's how it all started and that's how
science got mixed up with technology and
mathematics uh with geometry meaning
physics with geometry because they fit
geometry within physics okay so
if you ask someone where does geometry
belong today they say it's within
physics
well not that geometry not the
measurement not the uh
values and units that has nothing to do
with science or with physics okay and
here we have a good old mr plato and he
said no let no one ignore geometry enter
here you know his academy
and uh so geometry had developed to a
point where these people considered it
you know holy almost you know they said
no no
anyone who knows geometry he's an
educated person everybody else is a
peasant go work in the fields fellow
okay so only
uh
educated people would enter there and
whether they have to know they have to
know geometry what was geometry well it
was uh working with units and um
numbers okay
and here's an example of that okay these
are the units that the um greeks had
okay
uh what where are they uh well they call
them units of length or units of
distance no neither
what it is what you're staring at is
distance traveled this is traveled by
what by the end of your measuring tape
you're unrolling the measuring tape and
measuring
how many feet from origin the
tip of your tape unrolled okay
and these were their units these were
the small units they also had big units
okay for like the mile and so on uh i
didn't put this in here but you get the
idea the idea is that
they created numbers on the one hand
which was the arithmetic the beginnings
of mathematics and you had on the other
one on the other side the units they put
them together and they had a numbering
system followed by units that they used
to measure what distance traveled
distant traveled by the end of your
measuring tape from its starting point
that's what it was all about
it still is as i say nothing has changed
okay
and so because of that a lot of these
greeks
were involved in analyzing distance
because they were trying to find out
something about motion
and you had like i talked about a couple
of weeks ago uh you had the um
parmenides
uh the
they were known as the iliadics and you
had zeno who also watched for parmenides
and what they developed is all these
paradoxes to show you that there is no
motion in the universe why because you
have not moved
the distance
you have not changed distance okay and
here's a xeno okay he says uh
um
this is out of the wikipedia okay for
motion to occur an object must change
the position which it occupies
okay yeah you have to have two or more
location in any one
duration-less instant of time
suddenly not only do you have motion
introduced you have time introduced okay
into the discussion about what distance
why should you introduce time or motion
in distance if distance is just
separation between two objects in
physics
well the only reason is that you're not
going to talk about distance you're
going to be talking about distance
traveled and that's when you have to
talk about motion and time that's how
time enters the discussion of distance
meaning distance traveled okay let's
keep that in mind
the air is neither moving to where it is
nor to where it is not
this is the reasoning okay that they had
it cannot move to where it is not
because no time elapses for it to move
there
okay
and it's not there yet
okay it's not the future it cannot move
to where it is because it is already
there
so no time has gone by again all related
to time this distance traveled okay
at every instant of time there is no
motion occurring
if everything is motionless at every
instant of time and time is entirely
composed of instance then motion is
impossible
this is how they concluded that there
was no such thing as motion the iliadics
okay of course the um
atomos as i discussed the other day they
had a different idea they said look uh
motion is a reality you're not going to
tell me there's no emotion here i'll
move my hand to prove it
so don't tell me there is no emotion in
the universe that it's an illusion that
it's illusory
no there is motion and we're not even
going to talk to you guys because if
you're going to go to that level well
then we have no discussion at all that's
more or less the way they handled it
and here's another paradox involving
distance and it's the famous achilles
and the tortoise okay and here we have
xeno again
and has the competitors start running
at the same constant speed so they're
running at a constant speed okay but
achilles is faster than the turtus
turtle or tordos can't okay so very
clear right tortoise runs slower than
achilles okay so after some finite time
achilles will have run a hundred meters
bringing him to the tortoise starting
point
during this time the tortoise uh has run
two meters okay so achilles runs 100
meters and he's now
where the starting point of the tortoise
was and by that time the
turtles moved two meters so the turtles
are still ahead okay and
it looks like you know achilles just
gonna catch up with him because he's
running at a constant rate but he's
always he has to reach the point
where the
turtle left okay so
every time he reaches the turtle moves a
little more and every time he reaches
the turtle moves a little more he never
catches up with a turtle that that was
the idea that was the
uh reasoning and so again with it they
showed that there is really no motion
okay
uh that there is no change in that it's
illusory okay
and so it says whenever achilles arrived
somewhere the turtle turtle has been
there he still has some distance to go
before he can even reach the turtle
okay so he never catches up with him
and so yeah greeks played around with it
uh the people who had nothing to do they
played around with all these
concepts and they tried to figure out
whether there was motion in the universe
meaning you know if there's no motion
and i don't know how they didn't think
that if there's no emotion there could
be time because they were talking about
time but not about motion but they said
there's no motion but they still talked
about time so what is time then you know
i mean you got to define it and
this was also again related to distance
really distance traveled okay
and here's a aristotle he takes on the
subject okay he does analyze zeno and uh
also the atomos and so he apparently
he's given credit for this i'm sure it
existed the the idea was there before
him okay
and it's a real paradox and it's uh here
is summarized nested wheels sharing the
same center okay so you have a wheel you
know you have the spokes maybe and you
have a small wheel and a big wheel okay
and uh seems distance by both circles in
one revolution so if the big wheel makes
one revolution the other guy reaches the
same distance but it's a smaller wheel
smaller circumference okay smaller you
know
radius smaller
circle
distance throughout by the larger circle
is equal to its circumference this will
travel by the smaller circle is greater
than its circumference okay so there's a
little paradox in there and again
they're talking about distance what
travel not about distance okay so
irrespective of the conclusions or the
reasoning behind it or the explanation
they gave we don't care about that i'm
just saying here that all these people
talked about distance traveled
not about distance not about separation
i want to keep that completely in mind
it's going to be important okay
okay here we have a couple centuries
later in fact a few more uh mr galileo
galilei and what does he say well he's
the guy who allegedly
threw two rocks from the tower pisa
which i think never happened okay
and i discussed that in the past okay it
was someone else who threw the rocks in
from in holland not in italy okay
anyways the distance traveled by the
falling body is directly proportional to
the square of the time it takes to fall
that was his conclusion i think he did
it with rolling
balls rolling down an inclined plane he
timed those and that's how he reached
that conclusion but what was he talking
about distance traveled
it wasn't about distance what is the
separation between the tower top of the
turn the
bottom of the tower he wasn't concerned
about that what was the distance between
on his incline plane between the top and
the bomb he wasn't concerned about that
he wanted to know how what is the
distance it traveled the balls traveled
right
okay so it was all about distance travel
i want to make sure everybody
understands that it wasn't about
distance the distance of physics
separation
okay and a little later we have this
fellow his name is newton and he wrote
in his book in his principia i say that
a corpuscle put in place outside the
surface of the sphere is attracted to
the center of the sphere by
a
force inversely proportional to the
square of its distance from the same
center okay so what was he explaining he
was trying to explain gravity okay
but again he's talking about you know
the motion of something towards
something else
he's saying what is the force of
attraction what is force well force is
apparently something that's moving okay
so he was talking about some
in some measure he was talking about
distance traveled okay and then he
continues if the attraction of a body by
another shall be far greater when it is
attracted in contact then when the
bodies may be separated by the smallest
distance from each other then the force
of the tracking particles in the distant
parts of the attracting body decrease in
a ratio greater than the square of the
distances from the particles
okay
what's the problem with newton well the
problem is that he did not realize that
that little distance there squared that
he's got at the bottom left there force
equals gravity mass mass over distance
square that distance is not distance
traveled that distance is separation
between the two masses m1 and m2
okay
and i think this was a big failure that
even
uh persists to this day okay so let me
show you here my take on this okay
that's that's where i'm going to get to
okay here you have the distance traveled
of force equals mass times acceleration
which is newton's second law at the
upper left okay that's distance traveled
because it's part of
acceleration the tension which i put
there which
they put as force equals g mass mass
over distance squared it's tension there
is no motion there it's only um
separation between the two masses okay
so force equals mass times acceleration
newton's second law does not
equal
newton's
gravitational law
okay we're going to talk about laws
one does not equal the other because one
has distance traveled and the other one
has distance and here on the right i'm
showing what the differences between
these are
uh in the case of um
you know the gravitational equation
distance is static there's a separation
okay
and that separation we call distance for
every value that you get in the
gravitational equation
you have a static distance
you can add them up and then you have
motion but until you do that all you
have is for every value you have just
distance that's not the case in in the
force
equals mass times acceleration newton's
second law there the distance is dynamic
the distance in the
gravitational law is between two objects
the distance
uh is traveled by one object in the
second law
then each frame in the movie unit picks
a static distance that's in uh newton's
gravitational equation that's not the
case in the
second law which each frame in the movie
is a cross-section of the itinerary of
one object okay
so uh we're talking about two objects
versus one object in all cases
uh number four there distance decreases
uh when uh acceleration increases and
that's not the case the opposite is true
for the force
second law
equation
distance is towards the
other object in the case of the
gravitational law that's not the case
for distance
in the newton's second law distance
travel is away from an unspecified
object typically the origin of that
object that is single object that is
moving
the distance is the measure of weight in
the case of the distance in the
gravitational equation distance is a
measure of
velocity in the case of newton's second
law and finally the
force increases when
distance decreases in the gravitational
equation force increases when distance
increases in the second law
so you can see there are differences in
these distances first of all
and it's because they always use
distance traveled that they never
discovered the differences between these
qualitative differences between these
distances
that's where the problem was okay and to
this day no one has discovered it and it
only got worse at the turn of the
century 20th 19th to the 20th century
right you have mr einstein come in there
and really it wasn't him it was people
who came before him i discussed that a
couple weeks ago as well but here it is
uh
we have the length contraction
which is the distance contraction which
is the distance traveled contraction
because they're talking about a distance
traveled and there you have the example
you have the observer dilation the
passenger dilation what are we talking
about well if you have a train and
lightning hits the front in the back at
the same time according to mother nature
right
the observer on the train is going to
see something different not what mother
nature
did but what he sees what he experiences
since he's traveling in the direction of
uh where the uh lightning struck the
front of the train
he's going in that direction the light
is gonna hit him from the front of the
train faster than it's gonna be from the
back of the train okay and because of
that he says no the lightning struck
first in the front of the train later on
the other one in the back
on the other hand a passenger that i'm
sorry the observer who's on the station
just watching that he should receive the
sig in a right in the center where
between you know the front and back of
the train if lightning hits at the same
time he's going to receive those two
signals simultaneously okay so what uh
all these people were saying at the turn
of the century is that these guys are
going to measure
distance traveled
by uh light and by everything you know
right they're going to
measure it differently depending on
whether they're in motion or not
especially if they're moving close to
the speed of light and so they talked
about what length contraction
that's scary stuff you know you've got
length contraction the length the
distance traveled
contracts
man that's deep okay
and then you measure this is a summary
of essentially what it stands for you
measure different distance traveled
right from different reference frames
that's what it amounts to okay and the
reference frames has to do a lot with
how fast you're moving etc etc so it's
got to do again with distance traveled
and not with distance and that's why
they got into all this mathematical
gibberish where they say oh distance
gets shrunk meaning you know the length
of an object gets shrunk
because the distance it traveled gets
shrunk what are we talking about
distance traveled or about length what
are we talking about you know i mean are
they the same are they the same from a
physical from from the point of view of
physics that's the question i'm asking
okay
and so here's uh
um
i got another one here
i missed one
okay anyways uh here's uh the definition
we have today uh the distance uh for
distance right distance a numerical
measurement of how far apart objects or
points are that's the definition you
find okay
and
in mathematics
in everyday physics right or everyday
usage right distance may refer to
physical length
no no not in science
length is not distance okay
and i like to synthesize it the way i
say it there distance is what lies
between lengths okay length is what an
object has distance is what
is between two objects okay and so to
confuse
the absence of an object with an object
we have a little bit of problem because
distance is related to space or is the
space what length is to an object these
are two
properties that are
should be separated you should not
confuse them you they're not synonyms
okay
and so
you look up the word length this is a
measure of distance so we have a circle
what is this well it's a measure of
length what is length it's a measure of
distance great we learned a lot
that's all we have today
and uh
it says in the international system of
quantities length is a quantity
not the
uh continuous uh matter from edge to
edge of an object but
it's uh the length is the quantity with
dimension distance
whatever that means
dimension distance meaning
meters per meters you know or
inches or whatever
so again these people are rolling the
measuring tape
and because they're
rolling the measuring tape they're
measuring distance traveled and because
they
have always dealt with distance traveled
and never at all with separation with
physical separation they never
discovered that newton's law uh
universal law of gravitation as it's
called
deals with separation and not with
distance traveled
whereas the force law uh second law
deals with um
you know distance traveled
and so we have separation versus
distance traveled they're not
qualitatively the same
and if they're not the same we have to
look at it from on physics point of view
and find out how they relate to each
other and what i have done in the past
and might do it again sometime in the
future is shown that it's got to do with
this principle of equivalence
right
it's related to that
which i'm going to deal with today
okay so let's get on with some of the
questions that people made
and here we have one fellow and he says
if you don't
[Music]
need time for an object to have two
location what is illogical about quantum
mechanics saying an object can be at
multiple locations at one time
yeah i get these kind of questions
um
i don't even think i need to answer this
question i mean this poor fellow
he thinks it's okay to have like i shall
there you know uh bobby at two places at
once you know and so the batter
i don't know which one is he gonna hit
i mean is this guy kidding me is he is
this guy for real
my poor god
oh yeah here's another fella and he says
what he says until we solve and can
fully see how mad how dark matter works
we will not be able to analyze magnetism
okay
uh i don't know what magnetism has to do
with dark matter but he says likely it
has some of its answers in a different
dimension we cannot find out
uh
how to see
yeah i guess uh god hides in some unseen
dimension
are these people kidding me are these
people for real uh you know i mean uh
they don't even research these things
they just blurt out these nonsense
uh statements it's just unbelievable for
me that people have even these ideas in
their minds
okay another vowel says
time is change
or the interval of change
well uh make up your mind is it change
or the interval change
we need at least one thing that repeats
predictably
to have a measure
you look at intervals as an intervening
period of time so obviously you cannot
say time is an interval of change
because interval is an interval of time
okay intervening period of time it's a
it's a synonym so you can't use the word
interval to define time or vice versa
that's one issue there are synonyms okay
that's one issue the other one is no
time is not just change there you have
change
uh
what time is it three o'clock
i mean as long as you don't have
anything to compare it against you have
no time
i mean if this is the only thing that
god created in the universe right and
then he himself vanished this is all
there is
so you have change
it's periodic change
what is time in this context
the only way you're going to have time a
measure of time is comparing it against
something else that is also moving then
you will have time as long as you have
this you don't have time okay so
no
okay here we have uh
paul says
einstein established time as a physical
thing whoa
yeah
time is a physical thing
like a rock you mean
time can appear to move faster or slower
way only things can move faster or
slower concepts cannot so i guess he's
saying that it's a physical object and
it can move faster or slower
okay
objects such as
earth warps time
time bending as it's called
oh my god geez
uh
bartender i'd like to have whatever he
had
but he continued he continues he goes
one hour on earth is equivalent to seven
years in space oh man i do want to have
whatever he had okay
five years on a ship
corresponds to roughly 36 years
i don't know sailor what what ship were
you on
[Laughter]
but this is what people believe i mean
they say all this nonsense you know
time warps time is an object
uh what is it uh
ten seconds on earth is five uh in the
in in the air
poor fella
okay uh another file says object that
which has shape i said that okay
and uh so people ask what do you mean by
shape
and yeah i put that as uh one of the
things that either well either
devil's advocates or loonies
say you know they're the people who are
going to talk about you know
uh what is shape why well there's many
reasons
that i've got for why we do not define
shape in science
it's only again devil's advocates people
who want to shoot the bull spammers
whatever who do that or maybe people who
are simply too
uh not intellectual
that uh you know ask what is shape okay
so let's go through it
uh fella says
he says it's never an idiotic question
to ask what is meant by a mouth noise
and he's referring to shape okay saying
that why that it's not idiotic to ask
for shape and he says it's not idiotic
to ask for mouth noise okay
shape
that with inward extension that with
death
that with a membrane that with an inside
and an outside okay
shape is synonymous with what exists
in my telling but is not to be confused
with outline your imagination of a shape
a shadow or a cartoon superman in other
words what you're thinking
imagination and cartoons don't have 3d
inward extension only an optical
illusion and a clever stan shading to
convince you
any single shape had better exist
regardless what else is or isn't out
there so he's saying that um
a shape is that which exists and not
that which you have in your brain
thinking in your mind you know because
that doesn't exist it has no location
and then he says uh shape plus location
is an irrational way to define existence
aha since
uh location is an intrinsic extrinsic
i'm sorry an extrinsic relative concept
that only arises in a universe with two
or more objects in other words if you
don't have another object you don't have
location if you don't have location you
have an object but you do not have
existence okay
in your formulation of existence as that
with shape and location in a
hypothetical universe with a single
object that object cannot be said to
exist on
uh
account of not having neighbors
okay in other words if if if it's alone
if it's standing alone there well then
um it doesn't exist it's just an object
that does not exist and you say how can
that possibly be i see an object there
it's a ball it's in the middle of a
space it's the only object in the
universe what do you mean it doesn't
exist
well to to honor the definition you need
another object for it to have location
as a minimum distance between two
objects and so without that other object
it doesn't exist it's just an object
that's the issue okay
and he said he ends that that the very
existence of a thing and you're telling
is not self-contained
in other words he says um you cannot
have a single object in the universe and
it uh exists
that the only way that we're gonna ask
that it exists is that
it have location
and for that you need another object
okay so what are the my arguments
against this fellow
is former thinking
first question is why shape why did you
ask to define shape
i mean there it's that which has shape
that's the definition of the word object
you could have asked what do you mean by
that
what do you mean by which
what do you mean by has
and i'll give you an example you know
i say i have
five cents
in my pocket
is that the same as saying that i have a
headache
or that i have a dream
i have a dream
um to have a concept is that the same as
to have an object
and so yeah
to define the word have
at least for the purposes of physics it
would be a little more difficult than
shape
and the word have
can only be applied to objects in
science
in physics
you cannot have a headache in science
even though sometimes
[Laughter]
you cannot have a dream in science you
can only have a penny in your pocket in
science
okay so let's get that straight
and so was it easier did you find the
word have or which or that than the word
shape why pick on the word shape why did
you pick that one okay that's the first
issue
okay and then uh he said uh
what is it that
shape is extension or something to do
with extension extension is a verb
so if you're gonna define object as that
which has shape and then say well shape
is a verb that shape is extension and
extension is a verb
and for a verb you need an object
well you got a little bit of a problem
don't you
and you need location that means you
need at least two objects
so
you've gone around in circles and bit
your butt that's all you did there okay
you can't use the word extension
to define the word shape or anything
another another reason is that shape is
a static concept extension is not
extension is a verb okay let's get that
straight okay there is no such thing as
uh
you know uh
extension of a
rubber band okay that's what we're
talking about we're talking about a verb
um so it involves motion meaning two
locations how about shape equals exist
which this guy proposed well uh i have
doubts about that because exists
requires location
you know an object that has location and
you must define object before you define
location
so
you can't uh again the guy chased his
tail around that's all he did
but most important of all it's context
this guy is missing the context all
together and all people who attacked the
or who asked for the word shape are
missing the context that's all there is
that's the whole problem okay if they
get the context right then they're at
least intelligent if not one of the two
they're either being devil's advocate or
they're not very smart that's there's no
other possibility well maybe there is i
don't know you tell me
anyways uh the issue here is whether
we're going to stay with the c-touch
definition of mathematics
and say that an object is that which you
can see or touch
meaning you're going to run an
experiment meaning that you need two
objects meaning that you can't see or
touch the table on the other side of the
planet let alone the one that the
klingon has on the other side of the
universe
so that means that you can't use the
definition of mathematics which is c
touch which is the one that everyone
uses out there in ordinary speech
especially the mathematicians and which
everyone equates with the word exist
because they say what does exist well
that which you can see or touch
so we can't use any of those definitions
what we're comparing here is the
rational definition which is shape which
is a universal property
all objects have shape if not you tell
me an object that you know of that
doesn't have shape
and we're comparing that against the
irrational definition of mathematics
so we don't have to go in in there and
say well what did you really mean by c
and what did you mean by touch we don't
need to
the ordinary meaning of the word see in
the word ordinary meaning of the word
touch as well as the ordinary meaning
notion of the word shape are sufficient
to compare see touch versus shape if
anyone doesn't know or understand the
difference between
c touch on the one hand and shape on the
other
he's got to go to a loony asylum
okay that's the only
solution for
him okay here we have another following
he says
uh e equals m c squared mass and light
are energy
okay
mass and light are energy okay i didn't
know mass was energy because uh energy
is equal to mass times velocity of light
square mass times some kind of motion
so it's i guess they're not equal you
know if you have mass in motion and
that's what energy is then mass alone
without motion is not the same thing as
energy
okay but let's continue energy is a
property that matter has
okay so energy is a property okay of
objects things
that simple equation is saying
everything is energy
well not everything uh because you just
said that energy is a property it's that
simple and then he says objects are
energy
things are energy
well you know under the definition of
science and under the definition even of
mathematics that ain't true
what's the definition of mathematics
an object is that which you can see or
touch and there's another one says an
object is a collection of matter
none of those uh definitions coincide
with this falsehood and those are
irrational definitions when you have a
rational definition like an object is
that which i shape well obviously all
that is crap nonsense poppycock okay so
yeah
uh
phil has a little bit to learn maybe
when he gets to high school
okay so here's a another one
translated into mathematical form
universe equals what object plus zero
object plus zero
he's uh saying that space
is equivalent to zero
what was object equal to one
so we have one plus zero is equal to one
is that what we're saying here
uh is the numbering system going to
replace physics
is math going to replace physics why did
he put this in mathematical form when
that's totally irrational
okay anyways he says can be removed from
bill's universe formula and becomes
uh he's gonna remove the zero right uh
universe equal object well yeah this is
what happens when people
have problems uh when when they are
irrational they they start with an
irrational um
supposition or a assumption or
[Music]
a hypothesis right
and uh and then they work their way to
this irrationality he says well we can
get rid of zero and just leave the
object
now you can say universe is equal to one
then you can then maybe be in line with
your train of thought and to say that
universe equal to one i don't know what
that means
you know and university to go to object
absolutely not because we need the the
separation between objects with s the
only way you're going to get that s in
there if you have space so universe is
not equal to object it's objects
with s okay the universe is finite
is it finite only if it's a single block
you know
and even in that case it can't be find
that because you would need space to
stop it at some point
and yeah if you have no space i guess
it's infinite
and if it's infinite i don't know what
kind of object it is because an object
is that which has shape
so again he reaches
an irrational conclusion because again
he's using the terminology all wrong
he's
the whole reasoning is irrational the
implication of its existence however
would suppose the location yeah you need
another object okay
for one object to exist you need another
object but to have its location there
must be a system with at least two
objects that are in contact and exist
uh i don't know about contact you don't
need to have them in content you need
the contrary you need separation you
need space in there okay
in order for it to exist otherwise you
don't have location
or three objects that are not in contact
so
again
people are irrational because they use
all these terms wrong they're uh they're
going around in circles that's what it
amounts to
okay
here we have uh
another he says but doesn't speed mean
distance traveled in time therefore the
definition is circular
well uh we were talking about that
lioness and uh she has a notion of time
okay she has a notion of time why
because she
intuitively
qualitatively thinks that she can catch
that boar why because
she knows she has a sense of what her
speed is
she looks at that distance
separation okay not the since traveled
she doesn't she never went to
school like i say there all she looks at
is that separation
and she knows her speed or has an
intuition intuitive notion of her speed
and she says i think you can catch that
fellow that piece of food
and that's why she takes
you know uh
a leap and starts going after the boar
otherwise she wouldn't take the trouble
you know uh the energy as it's called to
waste any energy as they say you know to
catch it
they wouldn't have to travel
at all
she would even start the only reason she
does so is she has an intuition between
her notion of what her speed is
and how fast that animal runs and the
distance between them so it's all
intuitive and israel said well dude you
know do you have speed but speed is
distance no speed is distance traveled
that's what he's talking about
it's not distant distance traveled and
again all these people make that error
because they use the notion of
mathematics
which is distance traveled not the
distance of science
okay and here we have another fellow and
he says uh time comparison of two
motions that's me sorry
and i'm saying time requires memory okay
and
what is it uh second hand on the clock
you know uh moves one tick mark and the
earth moved 30 kilometers so you're
comparing two distances okay that's all
you all it is in this case distance
traveled to distance traveled and that's
what uh what your what time is
if you just compare two distances you
don't get time okay
yeah just you get more distance
and so fellow says if time is two
motions meaning that there okay how is
it that we have plank time in light
years one motion from point to point as
a measure of time
uh
well one issue is that light year is not
a measure of time it's got the word year
there it confuses everybody and so
this file is confused as well no light
year is a measure of distance traveled
okay so let's uh put it up there so that
people are aware okay this is it
uh
we look up the definition of the planck
time it's a length of time at which
no smaller meaningful length can be
validly
measured due to indeterminacy okay
indeterminacy being heisenberg
uncertainty principle planck time is
roughly 10 to the minus 44 seconds
meaning if you put one over 10 and 44
zeros that gives you an idea how
how many seconds or portions of a second
the planck time is okay and then you
have the light year again it's not a
measure of
time as this thought it's a measure of
distance
distance a beam of light travels in a
single earth year which equates to
approximately 9.4 trillion kilometers
okay if you do the calculation uh you
get this earth is approximately 30
kilometers per second okay
and in a year it travels 31 and a half
million seconds okay that's how many
seconds
are in a year
light travels 300 000 kilometers per
second in one year it travels that big
figure there 9.4 trillion kilometers
okay
because it travels at 300 000 kilometers
per second you multiply it times those
numbers of seconds in a year and that's
what you get that's the distance you get
in a year 9.4
trillion kilometers and then light
travel you the conclusion is light
travels at 10 000 times the
speed of the earth okay
so this is essentially
what you have uh so you need two motions
again you need uh the motion of the
second hand
and the motion of the earth
two motions in order to have time and so
this fellow doesn't understand that and
obviously if he doesn't know that a
light year is a measure of distance well
all bets are off
okay another fellow says
whatever begins to exist has a cause
okay how do you get something to exist
can you can you show me the blueprints
of how you get something to exist
how does something begin to exist
see these people are are mixing things
up they they think that a transformation
uh like when you
make a baby they say oh the baby began
to exist
no no you just turned some atoms into a
baby that's all you did you just made a
transformation that's all you did
uh
you morphed something into something
else that's all it is um
you know and uh anything that you make
uh you make a machine what did you do
you took all these atoms that were metal
maybe and you turned it into a machine
you turned all these atoms that were
part of a tree and you turned it into a
table
and they call that
uh
beginning to exist
no no you don't the table did not begin
to exist okay you can't talk like that
in science okay tables don't begin to
exist okay and the only way you can talk
about beginning to exist is you have an
object and suddenly it acquires location
because that's the definition of exist
an object that has location
what does it have location with respect
to
another object
so there's got to be distance between
the two objects
at least
if not more okay and now you have
location
okay and location is simply an object
that has distance with respect to all
other objects okay so an object cannot
begin to exist meaning that something
pops in meaning space converted into an
object somehow acquired length width and
height and look the rabbit is there out
of nothing
and suddenly it has distance with
everything else so you do not begin to
exist not in science unless you can show
us what the mechanism is that god uses
to turn nothing into something
that's that's the challenge for you just
show me the mechanism and we'll gladly
talk about the beginning of existence
okay another foul says uh a belief can
be true
yeah
or false a hypothesis is a justified
belief
okay that is not known to be true well i
mean
justified is just another word for
belief who justified it the probe
the dalai lama
i mean you can't say justified belief
because that's belief belief or
justified justified justified is belief
belief by someone who says i think it's
justified well i don't think it is and
so who's right
so justified is it's just another
unnecessary word put in front of belief
when people talk about knowledge or in
this case hypothesis is hypothesis the
same thing as knowledge because
justified belief is what um
what knowledge is justified true belief
okay
i guess a hypothesis is a justified liar
lying belief i don't know
you tell me anyways a hypothesis is a
belief that is backed up by some
supporting evidence
again belief evidence has to do with
belief you
provide evidence to convince someone to
persuade them to change their mind
so to say that it's backed by evidence
how you're introducing more belief so
whenever you say justify whenever you
say evidence and it's supporting
evidence it's all belief
okay a theory is a substantiated
explanation okay that's more belief
substantiated means it's just more
belief
okay
uh for example take the theory of uh
of
relativity
workspace
mark time
okay so do you believe in warm time
and that's the explanation they give so
is it substantiated well all the people
at nasa believe
in what time they feed it to you and
a lot of people out there believe in
you know warped time so it's just belief
and they say what's substantiated
substantiated by whom by nasa
don't make me laugh okay
uh
explanation for an occurrence that has
come to a conclusion a judgment or
decision belief
decision by whom judgment by whom who
who called himself who designated
himself as a judge
these people talk about believing they
say no no but it's justified you know
it's uh uh
what is it uh
it's a uh
it's got evidence behind it it's got you
know solid evidence yeah more belief all
we have is belief belief belief and
belief
consistent with repeatable observation
experiment yeah repeatable by whom and
whether they come out with that
more belief
no we care about
mechanisms because that does not rely on
belief you observe
and you understand and you can explain
how the window broke and you say yeah a
brick went through the window okay
that's not a belief that's
a mechanism
now the other guy said no it was a
crowbar the other guy said it was a dog
that jumped through the window everybody
has his own belief his own mechanism but
whichever mechanism you get is an
objective mechanism this guy says a
brick went through the window and that's
why the window is broken and the glass
is on the floor
so it's straight forward okay the the
mechanism is now whether you believe it
was a dog the crowbar or the brick well
that's a separate dish that is believed
okay uh we have some more people in here
they come up with these
good questions
uh if i get it up there
hold on let me get it up here fell to
the other side
phil says why do we need to know why a
spoon falls down
oh my god these people for real
physics tells us when it'll fall and how
it'll fall meaning you know
acceleration distance travel that sort
of thing that's all it does no that's
what not what physics does that's what
mathematics does
mathematics just tell you this is at the
rate it fell or yeah it's going to fall
down a prediction you know it's going to
fall down at a certain rate that's what
mathematics tells you that's not science
that's not physics okay
that's just description
it's the explanation the irrational
explanation that follows that turns it
into mathematics okay
think about it like tabulating a
spreadsheet of numbers seeing a pattern
and then compressing this pattern into
an equation
yeah nonsense we don't use equations in
science okay just like i said we need an
explanation
of why this pencil falls to the floor
okay that's what we need we need an
explanation and that's why i said what
do we need to know
there's nothing else to it what's wrong
with being magic if it being magic if it
works
technology these people confuse
technology no science is not about what
works
science is about explaining a mecca's a
mechanism so that you understand it not
if you can make something out of it and
works and and you can patent the device
that's not science that's called
technology
and what he was referring to was this
you know the spoon falling
there it is
okay so yeah
let me get it out of here
okay so yeah uh
uh
all these people are
i mean this this portfolio is saying we
don't need to know why it falls what
causes it to fall what the mechanism is
for it to fall
and that shocks me it means that these
people aren't even interested in that
subject matter which is physics and
what are they doing in physics
if they're just going to be measuring
and saying well it works and i can
make a little device and patent it and
make some money
what's that got to do with science with
understanding how the universe works
which is what we've been trying to
figure out for two thousand five hundred
years now at least if not more
okay uh a fellow asked me
he says uh
do you believe in a god
well no the people who believe or don't
believe are known as atheists agnostics
and theists
they're not known as scientists a
scientist is a person who does not
introduce belief at all into science
into
his dissertations into his explanations
he just gives you a mechanism so that
you understand how the thing works
and once you understand it we're done
with science
you know if you don't understand what's
the movie ten times because it's all
mechanical you should be able to watch
it and and see
how it works you know mechan
mechanistically and uh he can fill in
the blanks like saying you know what
caused it to work and so on that's
science but to say that you know you
believe in god and i don't believe in
god and i proved that god exists and i
don't know if god exists or not all
those are beliefs all those are opinions
they have nothing at all to do with
science so whether i believe in god or
not is irrelevant okay
mainly because you know it's
unscientific to say that you believe or
don't believe in god that's why it's uh
it's a question you should not ask me
okay i do science here and everybody
should be doing science okay you should
get rid of this belief word okay it's
got nothing to do with the existence of
god do you believe that the chair exists
work with that one first okay
does the chair exist
and if you can figure that out okay do
you believe that the chair exists that's
the question you want to answer
then you don't need to worry about stuff
more complicated stuff like god you know
deal with something small like does the
chair exist does the ball exist does the
tree exist do i believe that the tree
exists
okay
and you'll find out maybe your answer
there
whether you should believe that god
exists or doesn't or maybe you're
perhaps
okay final issue fella says
math confirms the dielectric force as
that force of gravity not mass oh
dielectric force whatever that is it is
a magneto
dielectric universe
magneto magneto dielectric universe and
we'll completely harrow
the standard model of cosmology and
astrophysics into a new factual
model of creation
big words here the ether is the static
dielectric magnetic force and that spins
to create the universe of direct current
from light to the stars galaxies and all
elements all the elements that have
evolved into life the spirit of this
creation
we are electric entities
oh my god what planet do you come from
take me to your leader
we'll see you next time bye bye